2020 was a dumpster
it's finally done let me tally up the
good things that happened
none the misery that we enjoyed is
pretty much constant but tragedy plus
time equals youtube content
so switch up your socials stop checking
your emails and i'll take you through
the year in excruciating detail
butterfly might sue me but please relax
and sit back because this tracks 20 20.
wrapped january 1st expecting a fresh
start a new year
2020 full of plenty things we're gonna
do here 2019 was a bust
fires in the amazon protesters in hong
kong boris getting brexit done but now
i'm looking forward that's
optimism no optician but i still got 20
20 vision
olympics up in june gold medals with the
clapping i got tickets to coachella
which is definitely gonna happen
admittedly we didn't kick off with the
strongest of stars australia's ablaze
cuddly kowal is charred
bush burning like moses kangaroos to
kebab and trump's getting impeached
because he sucks at his job still
at least he hasn't started world war
three an american drone has killed
solimani
it's technically a war crime but usa and
i'm hearing on the news about this wuhan
play i'm sure it's nothing
let's not overreact for no reason megan
and harry quit the crowd to start
a spin-off season paul the royal family
shove it who responded with gasps and
moved away beyond queen lizzie's lizard
he grasped it's only been a month but
already it's hella dramatic
and then kobe and his daughter lose
their lives in calabasas
helicopter crashes talent vanishes
tragic no way is 2020 getting
any more traumatic february we ain't
talking about a virus but a parasite
cinematic magic from korea the southern
side best picture winner bite and watch
in amazement for what a great idea
hiding out in a basement
democratic primaries and bernie's right
up there and he's once again asking joe
stop sniffing here
yang gang panic because the man got no
delegates bloomberg finds his bank
balance trying to stay relevant
kansas city ring winning super bowl
miami j
lo singing over 50 still a mummy shakira
sharing spotlights for the halftime
songs
giving dads across america those full
chubs and on the subject of republican
with sexual
urges harvey weinstein getting served as
just desserts it's a fitting in
lock him up discard the key he's going
down but this time consensually
marching on this month's got me feeling
positive i'm vaguely aware the choice a
word seems ominous big trouble in china
olympics postponed now to eat my morning
bats and check the dow jones
if you speak mandarin your flights are
now cancelling all of this caused by
someone hankering for pangolin
kobe 19 virus without equal you'll still
get it even if you missed the 18
out just like stars no it got tom hanks
another bowl of
stars still i'm learning new skills i
would go in the earth unless i have to
catch a bun zoom a new app that i'm
loving
sweatpants on the couch ac on the switch
tiger king on netflix carol baskin's a
[ __ ]
sure quarantine's weird with his valleys
and peaks but if we just stay home it'll
be done in two weeks
[ __ ] soon [ __ ] sourdough it's all
[ __ ] agony and [ __ ] italian singing
on the [ __ ] balcony you've been to
the
it's been a whole month i bought a gun
when will this [ __ ] stop i'm sick of
watching lip-synching snippets on
tick-tock now they're cancelling sports
i swear on my own i'll take a governor
hostage
i guess i'll stay home another week
glued to the news kim jong-un's got
kovid
and bojo too democrats see fit to pick
casino fella who says it's safe for us
to vote while he's still in his cellar
i'm doing workouts on youtube my floor's
the gym
and i learned how to pronounce
hydroxychloroquine but it's still
getting too much i'm having trouble with
sleeping transplant to drink bleach
start to sound quite appealing we're
still banging pans to show support for
all the workers as we're invaded by
hornets who saw purposes to murder and
when you think the whole year can't get
more absurd
9-1-1 is called on a black man for
watching birds it's a cruel summer
coming bodies stuffed in trucks an
unjust nation about to self-destruct
inequality rife racism a scourge so grab
your balaclava we're doing the purge
unemployment off the charts but they
protect the elite
cops shooting black people down in the
streets black lives matter at the
protest proclaimed george floyd brianna
taylor say their names
so much anger and division that it's
hard to make a joke but then a small ray
of hope from the spacex bloke
starting to unite us we all think the
same elon musk's kid has a really dumb
name even protests don't stop and in
lafayette square
a photo shoot for trump with tear gas in
the air i'm not exposed scripture but
i'll give a recital
thou shall not assault your citizens to
pose with the bible trump learns about
juneteenth because he's impulsive makes
plans for a million fans to rally in
tulsa maga hashtag taken over by the
k-pop stamps
in reality attendance was as small as
his hands the kids are all right they
can't trust the fake news so proud boys
make noise about confederate statues
linking arms around a general
gathered outside in a polo shouting yola
for some racists to die
chisley maxwell was epstein's paedophile
leader she's arrested i'm sure she won't
kill herself
either antifa keep themselves busy
smashing up shops no one defunds the
police
but they do cancel cops so it's six
months down six more to endure
in this first half of a trashier to be
sure i'm not saying it was all bad all
of the time
there was an office reunion admittedly
online john krasinski had good news and
for one week we sang happy birthday two
times through our washing our hands
there was ufo footage even though it was
cloudy brad and jen reunited we got
crushes on fountains looking forward to
the second half we're surely through the
worst of it i hope wayfair starts
including kids with all their purchases
july i'm gonna get my hair cut by a
professional august bite then bite and
will emerge from his hiding i hope the
stimulus package gets a few more
sponsors i hope ruth bader ginsburg
holds on a bit longer one thing we can
be sure of though so much will change
elon musk's kid will still have a really
dumb name 2020 completed and as it
receives in the review recitals to help
you remember this apart too so i'm
taking you through all the news that
occurs from july to december
improbable horrors historical happening
is simply unstoppable
not comical so i'll chronicle all of
these obstacles quickly as possible
we're already exhausted
looking back at all the damage done
disney plus releases us from boarding
making an available hammer
maybe he'd write his way out of this
misery but i'm not messing with that
just don't think it's that interesting
listening to history something's been
wrapped so many conspiracies spreading
online i'm having some trouble just
choosing one
hollywood liberals extracting
adrenochrome what would we do with that
aussies in melbourne are not done for
months it's not a good day mate
call that a knife this is a knife is it
a knife or is it okay celebrities
twitter accounts getting harsh elon musk
that bitcoins
ammonium nitrate are rotten in lebanon
cali the fires are spreading
they're violent and cruel and ruining
lives almost as many as ellen
north korean leader in a coma called
that kim jong-il
is arrested cardi and megan hook up for
a banger excessive vulgarity features
right wing widow ben shapiro can only
say whereas p words
pretend it releases his cinema showing
that nolan's so dangerous when will we
learn
popcorn with the side of kobe men
[Music]
young age you're twenty-four i'm i have
gone mixed up with what you expect that
you'd get comparing her to biggie smalls
schools are reopening students attending
cause classes in person can't wait
i've grasped my eyes where ladle are
using deciphering mortality rays
presidential debates commencing in haze
trump sits down back to the proud boys
shut up cause he died surprised from a
loud noise r.i.p to rbg
gop can't hide their enjoyment trump
voice is a choice for a pro-life judge
to proceed with a lifetime appointment
that's acb while aoc plays among us with
ilhan on twitch
and bad guys online try to body shame
billy saying island stay clear of the
fridge
van halen finally taps out in the bubble
the lakers succeed
president trump has covered being rushed
by traffic or walter reed his daughter's
report is doing well just a sore
and a slight thirst he recovers while
binge queen's down there which he loves
because white first nasa discovers the
moon some water is possible there could
be life
that's here another place that we've
discovered is whatever men should hear
us
in kamala divided by plexiglas the whole
thing just flies by except me i'll under
this old face
november 3rd election night trump abide
in selection time falling by mail could
be destined to fail so we recommend you
get in line
humans go red in the florida keys if we
trap results in the big screens we won't
even know the results for a week
midwest you pricked ease her records are
broken and so stone he's hot even though
he exceeded his polls
and democrats got why republicans know
that they only got votes because they
stole
count every legal one the quote those
dominion machines must be evil
tell us how you did it joe i guess i was
chosen by millions more people
playstation 5 is released but you better
be quick or willing to pay more
and if not at least you can play
cyberpunk at 10 fps on ps4
obama's been busy with writing and
finally releases his memoir harry styles
an address on the vote cover there goes
my no fap november
dolly parton's be funding our vaccine
though there are some side effects
it'll keep you working nine to five but
give you massive breasts
advice is ignore to not travel for
thanksgiving temps in a massive calamity
and we all have on place to fly back to
our childhood homes eat turkey and
murder our families fiction protections
expiring
congress is shamelessly facial mcconnell
decides that we can survive on half we
got given in april
government secrets are had by the
russians security's so overwhelmed
they want to embarrass america we
already did it ourselves britain is
finally brexited
boris declares no crisis preparing to
trade with the world's new export
a mutated strain of the virus vaccine is
finally here prioritize elderly people
that's all of our leaders
so mike pence will survive and i won't
die
done a whole year without precedent all
of us living our lives in the precipice
every economy suffered from losses
unless you're investing in therapists
but look on the bright side next
pandemic will be ready
who could have predicted this [ __ ] show
hindsight 20 20.
you